I THINK INPRULD BELDY
INS  K MIKEOLE BY TAKINTES THAT
>> ALESE IN
WELCOME BACK TF THE
UNION."
MP IN AN
INTERVIEW AT MAR-A-LYING
N'N'PIMIKE PENCE WERE HE
THAT INTERVIEW WASH SUSAN  R OF
NEW E DIVIDER.
PANEL JOIN
US
KINGGE.RSN TAKING VOTES AND
DID NOING WRON
H TRUM TO YOUR POINT, WEPENTE OG
THAN TR THCO
E FORMER MAR-A-LAG
PRESIDENT, AND I DON'T THINK
THERWAS A SINGLE
A NOUN AND AERB AND A PERIOD
ATTACHED TO  A LOT ONTABOUT  BU
BOTTOME  TRUMP WASTEINFININGVER.
WE WERE IN THE NOW FAMOU
HE JUST SUNDH E,
AS LIK IN ELBA BUTETBA>> YOU WO.
WORKEDMPT YO
SURROUNDED BTHPINGS OFWE CF ALT.
THATOMH .
I THINWE HE'S HA
HARD TIME OBVIOUSLY.
I H.HA'S L GONA NT
INTERESTITHERE WAS NO, A,
TO DONALD TRUMP THS PRESIDENUT D
McCONTINUED CIAL TO IT.
EVERY MAJO  TRUMP SLL NG TO BE A
E HAA HUGEAVE TH
RECOGNIZE TH IS WHAT WAS ITING
PED AIT  IT.  DIE
THOSE STFROM
COMMIT TT OUAG
ARN HOW BETTER
TO GET WHAT  WANTED THE
A SEAL WHO REGULARLY OBSERVED
UMP IN THE OVAO THE ORS INSIPA P
CAPABLE OF LEARNING WH
VELOCIR.HRCOTR TDEMOCRACY.A
>>F URISUCKLE BECAUS
OCIRAPTOR IS UTS DEEP OBMA FORS
WHO DID THEIR JOBSELECTION, TAAA
DEMOCRACY.E GETTING -- I
ANTO , BUT MORE STRATEGIC
ABOUT HOW HEIL.
>>NK L
RAT ENDS UGETTIND IN 202RES OUG
TH WHETHER WTO LOSE ANOTHER NAT2
D LUOUHI
I THINK THE HER PEOPLE
WHO GIT YOU WANT T VIE
ABBOTT, AND GOVERNORF FLORIDA,SS
RUFOR VAOUPIOFFROM TEXAS
TWO ANG GRANTS
SENT TO INAR COD.
I WANT YOU T TO L REVEREND IN
YASAY.
DETELY
INEYARD PRETTY NOWHERE TO GOLAF
TURNED OATERWERE,  HLE WHOHAD
PAYING OURON.RIC
>> I THINK ONEF TH
THAND ABBOTTO MAKE WITIS
KES INFLUXMAHAINARTHEY'RE NOT ID
BECAUSE THGOED THEM
I DON'T KNOW TGOE
SP IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE BEINGOLT'S RIGHT.
OBVIOUSLY YOSATS
CTF ISLANDNG OUT
AND IN
HELPD AS
PAWNS ORT OF GROTESQUE
S THE FLD THAKRUM IN
BLAN
BARKER  SERIOUSLIW HE'S USING A
NOMINN 20ORCAN, THEY'VERY LIKEA
E DO OWED THEM ANIN
UNG
ATIOE IN PARTICULAI ORS SEE THAT
THE AR DONALD TRUM
CREATED FOR HIMSELF IN POL>>OWO?
4 HOURS BEFORE THEAR
AND ROUND THEM UP AND THEMY. PE
E CARE OE.
TO TRY TOON MATHN ARIZON
S TO MAKE A LARGER
INRTTHE CRISIS AT THE BORDER IS
AND THOSTOWNS RE. THE POINT
I'M NOT TYPICALLY A FAN OF
Y TROLLING
I FEEL TROLLED EVERY DAY
SEE THE WHITE HOUSE PRETNT
AND TH
HE
ISURS
.ROBLEM.
THEY MADE IT.
WE'RE ING ABOUT IT
>>?N MAKE A POINT ABOUT
ITAN HAV
A CONVERSATION ABOUT E IMMIGRATO
AND ADDI MORE MONEY TO SUPPORT
BORDER STATES, USING PEOPL
ASICALE ARLEEINGTHE REPUBLICAN
TAKE CARE OF
I GET EMOTIOG ABOUT E WERECILIT
THIS IS WHAT THIEMEMBER WHEN WET
THES MISLED.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WEREOISO
APPOINTMENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FOR MONDAY
HE SETTING THEM
NATIONAL SECURITY STOP.
VICE PSIHENETWOR
WEEK THE BORDER ISE. NOT
SQUALID AS OVUSAN
CONDITIONS.
HA BRUNT.
THAT SAID, IRE
STUNT ONT EVERY LEVEL.
WE KNOW THST RELOCATG PEOPLEHIE
Y, MIG
E SOMEINFFSTATES.
AS PAWNS.N
IF THIS WAS FO B
GOVERNOReSANTIS,VE
LAO HOUSE UR
THESE PEOPLE, UPS  CANMS AND ME.
AS MEANTFOR
THE THF AMERICANRIERSATION.ION A
POLITICS.
I REMEMBER HAVING THESE SAME
WE'RITWA, THE LEFT DT TO
NOTION THATHE LE TO SOWE HAD A L
WOULD HAVE PASHOUSE.
IT WAS JOHEHPUBLICANS THAT WANT
ITA OUIMMIGRATION
>> THE LHE LEFT AND E
NT, ANE
PROBLEM.MIGRANTS AREOM
ELR
IS OPEN.
NIRA STOPS USING THAT LANGUAGE A
ERAND BORDER AND GETRITING T
SECUTYNTCRISIS.
OFFICIAL WHO TOLD ME THE RSATWI
GREATEST MISTAKE OF GEORGE W. A
COMING OUT OF THATTORY A
IO